foreign
[Music]
wow yeah I've been the males are cooler
and his brother go away
and then we uh are we safe right here oh
you're safe you're safe they just
finished off last night's kill okay good
yeah that is insane okay
he's just letting you know see the way
it works with lions is the females do
the hunting the males protect the pride
well protect them from where usually
from other Lions any line from outside
the family comes into their territory
Cuda and Kauai will leap onto it start
ripping it apart limb from limo die
trying
it's the law of the jungle
okay okay
you're up here
huh
[Music]
foreign
I'm gonna try and come to you okay
do you understand that money I'm gonna
try to come to you oh
um
I'm not alone what
he's staring right at me the lion is
staring right at you oh my God why would
he do that
son of a [ __ ] is staring right at me
that we have to go and get him down
right man what's going on natural
I didn't know any better I'd stay on the
beat
I'll go
get away from the car now yeah
it's right there
[Music]
thank you
here we go
hey look out the window welcome to my
party guys
[Music]
thank you so much for having us this is
my chance to reconnect with the girls
this little bump right here that's you I
still miss her every day
Step At Me
what's that there's something Crossing
up ahead
stay in the car okay just stay in the
car yeah okay what's he saying devil
need anything like this
multiple attacks without eating a spray
Lions don't do that at least no lion
I've ever seen
[Music]
go back to the calls
breathe slow down
we're in his territory now
foreign
it's only law that matters
so they've got guns you shouldn't be out
here
I've got to get my girls out of here
I need you to trust me right now
I'm coming back
don't you move okay
huh
we're gonna go
you can feel that sort of sense of
survival that Primal Instinct that you
all have in your adrenal glands are
going you're scared you're petrified
right now
Beast is about a family that is in Peril
that is in pain did Mom shoot smoothies
this little bump right hand that's you I
still miss her every day their
relationship has been strained so they
take this trip to Africa where Mom was
from this is my chance to reconnect with
the girls they're going back to her
Village to her roots
where's everybody
hello
what happened in here
what did this I've never seen anything
like this
multiple attacks without eating its prey
lives don't do that at least no lion
I've ever seen there's more
you've got a family that is going
through an unimaginable situation now
they encounter this Rogue lion and they
must fight for their lives
breathe slow down we're in his territory
now
[Music]
this isn't just any line this line he
was part of a crowd that has been split
up broken up by poachers the lands are
taken from the animals their Prides are
killed and in the end they will strike
back
one side is fighting for his daughters
and on the other side is literally
fighting for his life
my director did an amazing job creating
a energy around this film The Lion is
coming from everywhere but you're not
sure when it will come that's the reason
that I will go to the theater to see a
movie it puts you in that mind state of
survival it is an experience like no
other
you know
okay what should I say you can just call
29 and Charlie
Charlie I can say that working with
Idris Elba is such a joy
it's my dad that's insane he was like
Daddy can you stop bringing up Bungie
okay Dad but it's really nice working
with Mr oh but he's really hilarious
he's very kind he's very lovely person
we got McDouble Martin and we've got
supersize
we found ourselves sort of getting
closer in real life so stay right here
just gonna jump out this moving car
he made me feel so comfortable after
takes just working with him is literally
a dream come true it's really gotten to
the point where he's like my second
father all three of us when we were
doing our scenes became a little bit of
a family unit really is quite
heartwarming it's amazing literally
amazing baby
[Music]
[Music]